this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for that kind
introduction and the invitation to be
here this is such a great group and I
love that it's everybody's eating lunch
which is fantastic
um and the the house is packed so I'm
very grateful for that
uh yeah so I'm going to talk about
um my work in coffee agroforestry I'm
not going to talk about my work in
strawberries today
um I have done some of my my work in
strawberries for my postdoc but I want
to focus on my
research in coffee that I've been doing
for about 10 years now
um but first
there's something going on here
uh first I want to just say why this is
so cool to be here I I think um
obviously I want to share my work with
all of you and that's exciting but also
what it means for me to be standing here
today in Cornell and I don't know if
you've ever heard about maestro
sholokotsi
Hernandez he is the what it's uh he's
known as a Founding Father father of
agro-ecological thought in Latin America
and he actually came here
um in the 1930s to study botany
uh here in Cornell and later founded the
school of agroecological thought in
Mexico in what used to be the belly of
the Green Revolution uh in the cement
and the national school of agriculture
in chapingo
and then really from there uh
agricological thought expanded uh to all
corners of Latin America
and he was really interested in working
alongside Farmers that were developing
um
varieties for uh to adapt their Agro
ecosystems but he also learned all this
incredible agrobiodiversity that was
being hosted in pestinian indigenous
communities in Mexico
so he was a professor at the national
school of agriculture in Mexico where I
did my
um my bachelor's degree in agroecology
so it just means a lot to be here today
I mean so thank you for the invitation
okay
so like I said I'm going to be
discussing today my work in coffee
agroforestry and just to give you an
overall picture of the type of work that
I do
um I'm very interested in how
Agriculture and environmental change in
agricultural management has effects on
biodiversity and then how biodiversity
relates to ecosystem functions ecosystem
services and how that in turn impacts
human livelihoods
so in this talk I'm gonna tell you a
story
um with two main components and first
I'm going to talk about why biodiversity
conservation matters in coffee and
coffee agroforest and I will focus on my
work in habitat complexity and
biological Pest Control looking at ants
and the coffee Berry border
and then I'm gonna flip that story a
little bit and provide provide some new
ones on biodiversity conservation in
coffee agroforestry and I'll talk about
my social science research looking at
the conflicts and synergies that emerge
when conservation biodiversity
conservation narratives and practices
meet the lived experience of Migrant
Plantation workers and I'm gonna this is
work that is coming from the body of
research of political ecology which
essentially looks at the
um the conflicts that emerge when people
try to access natural resources in both
natural and managed systems
okay so just to situate uh my talk I'm
gonna be talking about coffee
agroforestry systems in Chiapas Mexico
which is the southernmost state of the
country
in this uh portion in this region here
that is bordering with Guatemala this is
the soconusco region
and this is how coffee agroforests look
like
um from the top of a mountain it really
looks like a lush natural Forest
and this is one of the most important
coffee regions of Mexico
in terms of you know the amount of
coffee produced
all right so let's delve into the world
of coffee
so coffee is a commodity that has in its
production distribution and consumption
shape people's social and sensorial
worlds for a very long time cheers
here's my little bit of coffee
and from its legendary Discovery by an
Ethiopian ghost Shepherd named Kali who
noticed the strange ways in which his
goats behaved after eating the coffee
fruits to its current worldwide
distribution coffee has dramatically
transformed landscapes in Social and
ecological relations while also
influencing
um people's livelihoods in many ways
and coffee is one of the most important
tropical crops on Earth
considering both its gross production
value and the number of people
families that depend on coffee
production
and today the coffee industry employs
over uh 14 million people across just
across Latin America
but also most coffee regions here in
shaded in Gray
are produced within tropical and
subtropical biodiversity hot spots which
are areas predicted to experience severe
uh climate change impacts and making
these places important for biodiversity
conservation but also as we adapt
and respond to climate change so these
places have really gained a lot of
uh sort of traction and importance in
the conservation and biodiversity
literature and work
all right in um
so coffee was introduced in Latin
America in the late 18th century
but it was not until
um the late 19th century that wealthy
European immigrants purchased land in
this unregistered quote unquote on
registered land in uh and invested in
coffee cultivation in this area this
obviously displaced Farmers uh which
were at that time mostly indigenous
who then later returned to this coffee
regions as Plantation workers
um and learned how to cultivate coffee
and later on they adopted coffee into
their own traditional agricultural
systems
wasn't really later after the Mexican
Revolution in when Land Reform occurred
that small farmers began cultivating
coffee at a smaller scale
so this tropical under story tree
has been cultivated on largest states on
peasant small Holdings and at many
scales in between and these are some
pictures of European coffee houses in
the 17th 18th century where by the way
way women were not allowed to go in but
this is where you know the important
political government conversations were
happening
um and this is a picture of a plantation
this is a picture from 1870
um showing coffee harvesting on a
plantation in Guatemala yeah so in Latin
America Coffee is um coffee exists in
this socio-ecological Continuum in which
multiple layers of complexity complexity
interact a vast diversity of social
groups labor intensities farm sizes and
extent of capital accumulation are
represented within this an overlap
within within the spectrum of ecological
complexity
and as such well coffee is cultivated in
a variety of ways with varying
vegetation structure species diversity
and composition and with a diverse
management intensity from The Rusted
coffee where coffee grows under the
shade of mature forests
to traditional polyculture
with a moderate management of the shade
to commercial polyculture uh with trees
of double purpose like fruit trees
legume trees to shaded monoculture which
is monospecific shade
all the way to the full sun monoculture
which has now become much more prevalent
in places like Brazil and Vietnam
all right so we have produced this great
uh amount of information in literature
around
um that that supports coffee agroforests
as an important refuge for biodiversity
particularly we've done worked on avian
and mammal diversity and this work has
shown that it's really in part of this
spectrum of ecological complexity
uh where intricate species interactions
contribute to ecosystem Services we're
talking about pollination Pest Control
carbon sequestration Etc
but also systems like this are support
supporting millions of farmers
livelihoods
and these systems are in fact Prime uh
spots for biodiversity conservation in
the tropics and they have gained uh
significant attention in the literature
and something we have uncovered this is
um uh Network that I have spent working
on for the past 10 years and uh we have
uncovered through many years of research
in this Forest that there is a very
complex network of species interactions
that are sustaining this key ecosystem
services
and so this is just a simplified version
of the complex Network that involves
four main uh coffee pests and disease so
we're talking about the coffee Berry
border
um a beetle the green coffee scale
um nipturin the coffee leaf rust uh
caused by the fungus himalay of
obstetrics
um and the leaf Miner a Le copter
acofella
and so in this really complex network of
interaction we've actually found that
ants play a keystone or keystone species
that are integral to the Ecology of the
system and they interact in interact
interact with this pests and diseases in
a variety of ways either through direct
predation deterrence indirect
interactions
and so the story that I'll tell you
about uh complexity and ecological
um interaction species interactions it
really focuses on this one particular
interaction here which is between the
coffee Berry border and
um ants and ant mutualists which are the
scales
so that's what we're going to focus on
um for this particular work
and the coffee Berry border is the most
important insect pest for coffee
it is widely distributed in every single
place where coffee has grown just most
recently introduced into Hawaii for the
first time maybe
um eight years ago or so
and this Beetle drills galleries inside
coffee beans
um where the um where this insects
reproduce
and they drill galleries in
um the boar attacks coffee berries from
the very early stages
and then the adults uh when they uh when
they're adult mate and they uh fly to
colonize new fruits but when damage
persists uh yields can be reduced by as
much as 35 percent this is a picture uh
from one of my students in when I was
participating in an illustria scientific
illustration class at UC Santa Cruz in
the Nori Center for Natural History and
we had students coming from uh design
and very interested in scientific
illustration and they drew a lot of
insects for me so I've kept those
because I just think they're just really
cool
okay um this is another scientific
illustration and actually ants are one
of the most important Predators uh of
the coffee Berry word the most important
natural enemies for the coffee Berry
border and of course uh insects are um
the the border is eaten by a variety of
taxa but ants really are kind of the
most important ones and they're really
abundant really diverse
um
and yeah this is uh Azteca but in
particular I'm going to talk about this
one Aunt who is a sticker series it's an
arboreal ant
in this particular ant asteka builds
this beautiful carton nest on the coffee
um on the shade of the trees uh in the
coffee Forest these are the coffee
little coffee trees and these are the
shade trees and this ants are building
their houses up there
but they like to come down to the
um coffee plants and that's where they
maintain a facultative mutualism with a
scale insect
and this um in this is a facultative
mutualism in which the ants protect the
scale in return for for food
and so as a result Azteca ants are often
aggressively defending scales from their
predators and maintaining High activity
levels near berries on coffee branches
so you can see this is esteca
ceresiosaur going extremely crazy Sugar
High
um finds a coffee Berry border and throw
it off of the coffee plants
all right so this is this is something
that is happening as a result of this
mutualist interaction
um and this is not in a speed uh sort of
mode is this actually real time and here
I am with a little little bottle because
I'm doing I was doing an experiment
looking at behavior
um and looking at uh sort of the the
interaction and I was putting the little
bottle just to kind of capture the
coffee Berry border because it was
happening every single time
okay so these are results
um from a study where we systematically
baited ants
um uh near coffee plants and correlated
the presence of ants to border
infestation
and so coffee plants with at least uh
one uh species of ant present had
significantly lower mean infestation so
here we'll see
um this is infested berries in the
y-axis and we have
um plants without ants had a
significantly higher
um
um percent of infested berries about
10.6 fewer infested berries in plants
with at least uh wand ant species on
coffee plants
so okay this tells us a couple a couple
of things and uh oh and of course we
could ask well what happens when we
increase the uh experimentally we
increase the coffee Barry border density
the effect of um of ant presence on
Border infestation it's maintained uh
even at higher density
um of the coffee Berry border
okay
so this
um this graph demonstrates that uh
plants with either of two dominant ant
species because ants a stick ions are
not the only dominant species
um have also significantly lower uh
percent of infested berries so this is
uh this is no ants this is a sticker
ants and this is or next most um
uh dominant and as a phytolic
synontropica
so they are sort of playing an important
role in controlling coffee pests in in
coffee in coffee forests
but this is really a result this overall
a robust biological control of the
coffee Berry border is mostly a result
of multiple species in track not just
one single species and in fact in
communities in shaded coffee forests are
generally diverse uh where species are
classified into several foraging and
nesting groups we have arboreal ants
Grand and we have twig nesting ants and
there's really really diverse and
abundant community
um so for example we have small
this is a sticker ants and they're too
big to enter the galleries of the coffee
Berry border
um so they they just uh take the beetle
with the mandibles and they throw it off
of the coffee plant where other ground
ants remove adults and brood from Fallen
fruits but we've also done experiments
um when this happens and other ants take
the adults
um like you can see in this picture here
but we also have this ancestral borders
of the plants like Azteca and we have
other tiny ants that go inside of the
galleries so there is a really diverse
um
Community it is a really diverse
Community not just in terms of their
um
um they're foraging strata but also
um in terms of their effect on the
coffee Berry border
so part of this of my work is very
interested in this species interactions
but also I'm interested
um as an ecologist in what explains this
incredible diversity we see in um in
coffee forest and then how can we
translate that into agroecological
management what does that mean in terms
of management
so here the concept of community
assembly is really really helpful and
this helps us understand how the
outcomes of agricultural management
which are translated into measurable
local and Regional habitat factors
influence ecological communities
so Community assembly is this process in
that leads to particular patterns of
colonization
of species and reflects survival and
coexistence so for example in coffee
landscapes
we can have a full Regional pool of
species that disperses to colonize new
places
passing through these filters which
could be different levels of food
availability micro habitats competition
parasite diseases you name it all of
these filters in the environment
are being encountered by species and um
under which then create this uh specific
Arrangements of the local community so
that's what a community assembly is
telling us and under this framework a
coffee system that provides a variety of
colonizing spaces
um
and food and nesting resources would
hold higher species diversity and
functions this is what we would we would
expect
um if we are thinking through the
community
assembly lens
so I also have carried out some
experiments in observations to look at
how this operates and I'm just going to
show you two examples of how habitat
complexity matters for uh the
biodiversity of ants so this is habitat
complexity uh sustained species
diversity and species interactions and
here um this is uh nmds that is looking
at sort of patterns of proximity in
terms of community composition and
something that we wanted to see is is
the community different uh in the
um the shade of the forest and is it
different from uh the species that we
find in the coffee plants
so um nnds provides this visual
representation of patterns of proximity
and so the closer the points they are in
between within groups and in between
groups the closer they are in terms of
this their species identities right so
what we're finding here is that the
composition uh the community composition
is different between strata so what does
this tell us in terms of
um
in in terms of a management and the
diversity of ants is that um enhancing A
diversity of nesting spaces for ants is
critical to promote their diversity and
potentially also their complementarity
so this understanding of
um Community assembly is also related to
Niche complementary
okay
there is another
um
did I miss something one second
there it is
no okay so the other aspect of
vegetation structure is
um it's uh sorry another aspect of
habitat complexity is vegetation
structure so we could think about the
diversity of nesting resources and um
inhabitat but we can also look at how
the vegetation is structured and how
complex it is
um and
vegetation structure is you know the
abundance of foraging substrates like
lyannis moss and bark the arrangements
of the vegetation the characteristics
how connected these resources are and I
mean you can imagine as a you know the
ants move from one place to another
their central place crusorial foragers
so they footage from a central place to
which they return uh with food for the
colony so all of these things are
essentially just Bridges to move
throughout the landscape so they are
important resources and Steve yanoviak
at
um
I think in Kentucky he's done a lot of
work looking at like physiology and how
these resources impact the how fast
these ants are anyways they have like
this fascinating work with and Mobility
but they essentially influence efficient
foraging the activity of ants in
um ultimately also species interactions
and like I said this is particularly
true for arboreal ants which use the
arboreal stratum as their primary
foraging substrate
foreign
in agricultural systems this knowledge
has been used to manage for pests and
enhance the ecosystem service provided
by ants and in fact
um this is the oldest method recorded
for biological Pest Control
um dating back 1700 years ago in ancient
China which involves the Citrus and
oicopholas maragina they have this
little tiny green butts that are just so
cute they're the Weaver ants
and they are used for the control of
insect pests in oranges
precisely using these bridges made of
bamboo to facilitate mobility and
colonization into other trees and
ultimately Pest Control
so this is knowledge that farmers have
used for generations to manage their
agroecological systems
um of course as we intensify
agricultural systems the ability the
connectivity for in this agricultural
systems is minimized is reduced right
uh this is something that we're seeing
in coffee agroforestry a significant
trend from going from uh forests to more
sun coffee
um which if you think in terms of
connectivity really reducing the ability
of ants to move move from plant a to
plan Plan B uh point B and then
um to carry out their ecosystem Services
right
so I wanted to see
if this is something that hinders eight
abilities to provide biological Pest
Control in the case of coffee
and um when I was I was doing my work
with ants I met a
um a farmer
who um told me that
they um
they they were hanging this little
strings uh from uh from the coffee
um the coffee Farms that the coffee
plants
and so I said well let's let's test if
that's you know actually something that
we see any effect on
and so what we did is that we
experimentally
um tested the effect of connectivity
um and looking at the effect of
connectivity on Ant activity on coffee
plants and whether that enhances border
removal and what we did is we this is a
shade tree that has one of those astika
and Ness here and we connected
um we'd randomly connected these plants
some of them
and we obviously left the controls
without connections
and then we measured the ant activity on
this little Bridges
but we also experimentally added coffee
Berry borers and observed their behavior
and so we measured the activity but we
also measured the removal of coffee
Berry borders
and of course ants were like Yay riches
so they were crossing they were carrying
stuff
um they were really immediately
establishing Trails on these connections
so that was really fun to watch but
about 75 percent of all strings placed
in the field where uh were being used
and um this work was featured in The
Economist not that long ago so if you
want to check it out
um yeah take a look at it
so so what did we find here we found
that connectivity
uh what did we find in terms of
connectivity affecting uh ant activity
um before and after placing the string
so here you'll see in the y-axis number
of ants per minute on coffee so
basically a measure of ant activity
before placing strings in after placing
strings and you can see that
antactivity increased in both cases and
both connected and uh in both control
and connected plants but antactivity was
always significantly higher on plants
that were connected
and this had
um an effect on coffee berry berry
border removal on control plants
um and connected plans you can see that
border removal was higher on plants that
were connected
so
um
so what what this is telling us two
things right on the on the one hand is
um it's telling us that this
connectivity resources are critical for
ecosystem services and if we think about
um these as a measure of habited
complexity and we want to manage for
biodiversity then we need to think about
increasing connectivity
now that is also a quite there's a lot
of questions that can emerge from this
like how viable this is in uh when we
were thinking about large-scale
agriculture
um
and the the other aspect of this is well
can we increase connectivity if we're
reducing the forest cover anyways right
so it really is
um the the central message of this is we
need the forest we need the shade
um trees and coffee forests to continue
if we want to kind of preserve the um
um the ecological functions provided by
this key
organisms okay
um and here I'm going to start kind of
switching my story a little bit and
these complex uh coffee Agro ecosystems
are of course important for biodiversity
conservation we've been studying them
from an ecological point of view for a
while
um but they're not just important for
biodiversity they're also fulfill a
broad range of Social and ecology and
economic needs of families
and so This research has my social
science research has primarily focused
on
um coffee farmers and Farm Workers and
um these are farmers who cultivate
coffee in less than five hectares of
land right so most of the most of the
work that we've done in coffee
agroforestry has focused on small
holders so they cultivate less than five
hectares of land
okay
um but let me give you a little bit more
of uh sort of the big picture uh
socioeconomic picture of coffee in Latin
America
so they do contribute to uh to the
economy of thousands of households all
throughout Latin America
and more than 60 of the coffee worldwide
is produced by smallholders yeah most of
the coffee that we're drinking is
probably coming from less than five
hectares off land
um but also in Latin America
smallholders is even more striking right
it's 80 to 85 percent
um let me just close this
there uh 80 to 85 of coffee comes from
smallholders in Latin America
but listen to this smallholders only
control 80 18
of the land
and this is actually a trend in uh or
globalized food system right we
increasingly see that uh larger uh
larger Farmers our larger Farms are sort
of taking over the production of the
amount of land produced in the world
right so in worldwide 30 to 40 percent
of coffee is actually produced in
large-scale plantations uh which depend
on Plantation laborers throughout the
year so when I was doing my work as an
ecologist
um I need to give you a little bit of
context is that a lot of the work that I
do in ecology happens in this
um
large-scale 300 to it's actually now 600
hectare Plantation
that hires wage labor throughout the
year it's not a it's it's not as a
ecological research within smallholder
Farms
so
um when I was doing my work I started
becoming very and I'm also from this
region so I'm particularly
um really interested and just personally
very familiar and and curious about the
people that come and harvest coffee and
coffee plantation so when I was doing my
work I would you know go and set my
traps and uh when it was harvest season
I would see Crews off uh Farm Workers
coming in with their baskets and they
were you know talking and you could I
started becoming really interested in
um in in social science research through
my conversations with the Farm Workers
so they would have
breakfast at like 8 A.M so I would sit
with them and eat my lunch and I just
started thinking
there's there's like an interesting
connection here between my ecological
research and the lives of workers that
come to this Farm like what is the
connection between the lived experience
of this folks and the work that I'm
doing in biodiversity conservation
so they kind of really got me thinking
about
you know I started reading a lot and I
realized there wasn't a lot of work
being done in uh in Farm Workers in
coffee forests because we mostly focus
on smallholder peasants that own their
means of production they can organize to
get better prices for their coffee but
we don't know much about well if what
happens with those premiums do they
reach the Farm Workers and things like
that you know I started becoming really
interested
so um despite being an important part of
the workforce for coffee producing
regions in Latin America Farm Workers
are one of the most marginalized actors
within the coffee production chain
um and it's just surprising that we
don't know much about their livelihoods
and
um
so Farm Workers work for a wage on big
plantations and away from home they are
unable to supplement food intake by
corrupts grown on their own land back at
home and can suddenly find their
themselves out of work
okay so hundreds of Migrant families
come to this region every year to
harvest coffee to pick coffee and these
are essentially like little uh coffee
towns embedded in the mountains of uh
Southern uh Mexico they're maybe about
two to three hours away from the main
city uh people don't have transportation
obviously so it's difficult to access
food
um and so you can actually find also
there's like a school there's a little
clinic
um there's you know uh like a basketball
court so they're like really there's
there's a whole you know life happening
in this coffee towns foreign
workers receive a feature elementation
which is a food voucher every morning
during the harvest season where they
about 4 a.m in the morning they wake up
and they go and pick up their ration of
food for the day which is beans
tortillas rice and coffee
and so that's what they eat uh
throughout the day
to give you a little bit of example so I
had just so many questions about
but here are just some of them
um well what are the contradictions that
emerge when biodiversity conservation
meets the lived experience of Farm
Workers how do Farm Workers perceive
biodiversity and coffee aggro forests do
they do they observe these things that
we as ecologists are looking at and if
so like in which way are they engaging
with sunsets
how do Farm Workers practice autonomy
and food sovereignty are these you know
passive actors that are just sort of
subject subject to exploitation and
forced labor or uh how do they practice
their autonomy and their sovereignty
and what are the implications of this um
to a sustainable agriculture but
probably most importantly today it's how
do labor shortages impact uh sustainable
agriculture what are the implications in
the future
so I'm obviously not going to try to
answer all of these questions today and
happy to continue the conversation
um but the work that I do in social
sciences is really stems from
ethnography and participant observation
this is um uh basically grounded in
interpretive anthropology which values
or emphasizes the importance of symbols
and experiences as well as individual
opinions to understand societies
um it's what some Scholars have uh name
deep hanging out or
participant observation and also I do
walking interviews and um with with Farm
Workers so here um the system tooth out
a picture from 2016 I believe when I was
finishing my doing my PhD
and you can see this is the family of
oramiga actually they do competitions of
who is like the fastest picker in ormiga
the family of Omega which means ant by
the way
this is how much like they would they
would probably Harvest about four of
these a day per person which is a lot
this is how much I was able to harvest
just in one single day of work with them
so um uh for for an entire harvest
season I uh did participant observation
so I I basically moved to the Shacks
with them I ate with them I cooked with
them we hunted armadillo at night
um we we just hang out I just hang out
with you well groups of families of Farm
Workers who basically adopted me and
they were like what is this lady doing
here
um and it was really fun and it was but
it was also a very eye-opening
experience for me
um and I I maintained my my friendship
with many of the farmers Farm Workers
that I met um during my PhD and I
continued to work with them um up until
now
so this is some work I published in the
Journal of person studies looking at the
conflicts that emerge when biodiversity
conservation meets the lived experience
of Plantation workers and um if I have
time I don't know how I'm doing with
time
wow
okay good so
um so here I'm just gonna show you some
of the the findings that I have from
that social science research
um just as a small historical vignette
these Farmers uh this farms uh sort of
emerged from the big influence of uh
foreign capital investment in the 19th
century uh they're mostly German Farms
that came and bought massive plots of
land and established there for
Generations now there's even a town
there called New Germany
uh but also this region is really famous
for its uh coffee route which is this
touristy uh popular destination in
Chiapas where you can take the Safari
and they take you to like a spa
different like spas and in far and
fincas and the farms and they tell you
about the history of coffee and also the
kind of highlights local flavors uh
both um
literally and figuratively as well
and this has been a very successful
marketing strategy for the coffee
industry here in really worldwide
um this idea of this images that remind
us of conserved natural forests or
places with vast natural resources are
kind of very prevalent uh you know when
you go and buy coffee and Trader Joe's
or whatever you can see this very
illustrous packages
um and I became very interested in well
what is the role of humans here in it
which seems really indefinable
um but this popular discourse of
conservation which uh Candace Slater who
has is a political ecologist has studied
biodiversity in the Amazon
um she talks about identic myth-making
narratives that actually uh obscure
people's lives and uh promote
inequalities in places that are you know
human dominated
so this are some quotes from Plantation
lodges and and also from TripAdvisor I
did a content content analysis research
and so a lot of people say a bit of this
place says who knew Paradise would smell
coffee it's nature Paradise Heavenly
Paradise amidst the rainforest what
you're getting is fantastic views and
Back To Nature with luxury an unbeatable
combination
so this is how that luxury Lodge looks
like
the coffee Farm
so biodiversity conservation it's
actually enhanced or enforced uh through
a narrative of exclusion in the
plantations and this is uh when I
started doing the work I thought I would
find you know Farm Workers telling me Oh
it's great to work in this you know
large Forest of Plantation but I
actually found a lot of evidence of
exclusionary narratives coming from
um
perhaps older versions of ideas of
conservation so here's people are
prohibited to hunt which is quite
problematic in a place that is kind of a
food desert in um in the lodge Forest
um so Candice later again she talks
about these places that seem like
representations of naturally or
seemingly natural landscape in terms
that consciously or more often
unconsciously evoke the biblical account
of the Eden
foreign
stories of nostalgia for a perfect past
or deep Fierce about continuing loss
but also it seems like humans be human
beings find themselves forced to play an
ambiguous or in a custom supporting role
so this is more kind of a theoretical
work that I've been doing looking at
idinic myth making narratives in Shea
grown coffee plantations specifically
focusing on the left experience of
Plantation workers
and this is some of the things that Farm
Workers would tell me that you know when
there's shade there is a lot of leaf
litter and it's frightening because
there are snakes it's also frightening
to go into the dense vegetation
and um they would also uh it was
interesting the way that they interact
with ants right that's really uh this
represents a new Nuance when harvesting
coffee and one of the important things
for managing uh coffee Berry border is
that you have to harvest all of the
fruits because otherwise you know the
Border will continue to reproduce but
harvesting coffee where you have a ton
of this asteka ants biting you it's not
fun
so this obviously brings interesting
contradictions and questions about well
what does this mean uh in terms of
management
okay
another worker said it's hard to pick
coffee here and worse when the weeds are
told
the coffee is very scarce we barely pick
any
and then they they were talking about
also some inequalities happening in the
Plantation uh that have to do with
essentially stealing people's labor
so but also people would talk about
neighboring plantations that
um were monocultures in where shade
wasn't being conserved at all and they
would refer to those plantations as
clean plantations even though there
would apply pesticides and fungicides
and all that stuff so um
really from the point of view of the
plantation laborer
my understanding of biodiversity
conservation was being like hugely
questioned it was very interesting
um
but that first work that I did on uh
peasant uh for the Journal of peasant
studies and thinking about
um I I talked a lot about inequality and
exploitation but also how
um
we're obscuring the lifestyle Plantation
laborers through these narratives but
also
um I'm interested in how uh local
agricological knowledge supports
agrobiodiversity and food sovereignty
among migrant agricultural workers in
coffee agroforce and this is some of the
work that I'm doing looking at what are
the synergies what are the benefits of
chagrant coffee what are people
perceiving
um and what is the contribution of
coffee forests to uh household food
security so we've been uh this is a work
that we did over the summer with my
students last last year looking at we've
documented all the species that Farm
Workers are harvesting from coffee
plantations
and here's a woman who's very agiley
took his her machete and just like
caught this plant and like she was like
oh this is for my tamales later tonight
and so we're you know talking with uh
families of Farm Workers about what is
the benefit of these plants and so
probably taking like a different look at
this edible weeds in the plantation
so
um yeah
in conclusion right managing for
diversity within Agro ecosystems
promotes ecosystem functions and
services
um
conserving habitat and resources for
insects of increasing agricultural
um in the face of increase increasing
agricultural simplification is really
important uh for pest suppression and
other ecosystem services
the diversification of farming systems
should also pay attention to the
socioecological trade-offs and conflicts
and synergies
but we must also change the Paradigm in
the conservation narrative to include
the lived experience of everyone that is
playing a role in the production of food
just Farmers but also Farm Workers
especially today after we've learned
from the food system under covet right
so with that I just want to thank all
the wonderful people that make my work
possible especially farmers and the Farm
Workers that put up with me asking
questions in the field but also my
funding in my collaborators in Mexico
University of Michigan at UC Santa Cruz
and my lab at Syracuse University and
thank you for the invitation again and
for having me here happy to take your
questions thank you
so uh first of all thank you so much for
a wonderful presentation I I think that
like just thinking about ecology and
social science in the same presentation
is so rare and it's so important
um and to that point I guess
um
like how do you recommend that uh land
managers and Farmers uh uh move forward
with a desire to conserve biodiversity
considering its benefits but also the
very real uh potential risks of things
like snakes and uncomforts of even
finances
how what what's the best way forward
to to kind of deal with this competing
realities yeah that's a great question
I think one of them one of the huge ones
is policy right and I think that
increasing the ability of farmers to
make uh
just living wage that is not just for
the farmers but also the people that
work in their plantations and addressing
issues of inequality within policy I
think that's that's huge because it
doesn't matter how much biodiversity
we're conserving if people don't have a
fair and just livelihood
um I think that needs to change through
policy and um and action from consumers
as well right
um in terms of what Farmers need to do
um
oh that is a that's a really important
question I don't know if I have the
answer to but I think we've we've come a
long way understanding how to manage
um
the shade in in coffee forest and there
is an important balance between how much
shade we have in a coffee forest and the
productivity of coffee so I think
partnering with Farmers
um
sort of following the sound science that
we know about balancing like 17 72
percent of Shade that's that's what
gives you like the most optimal
productivity but also conserve
biodiversity right
um rather than saying we need to
conserve you know we need to have just
rustic
shade brown coffee plantations right I
think that partnering with farmers and
scientists is really important
a quick question I was just wondering
how did the Farmers you your
research did they consider that like
what are you doing or hey you know and
how did you kind of convey yeah the
importance for them longer term yeah
that's a really great question I went
through a very painful and lengthy
process of IRB to be able to do this
um it was required a lot of
conversations with the farmers about
what they wanted to know and it was I
was surprisingly I was pleasantly
surprised about their interest actually
um one of the things that I did in that
person studies paper is I don't want to
paint Farmers as the evil ones like
plantation owners are not because a lot
of the time just like most large-scale
Farmers they are in huge debt they are
dealing with constantly changing
policies to be able to uh deliver you
know good quality coffee that they could
that can be registered as organic so
Plantation Farm plantation owners or
Farmers the owners of the plantations
where and
uh
opposed to understanding the conditions
of the Farm Workers like they know
what's going on
but they simply are not at the top of
the food chain right they're dealing
with middlemen they're dealing with
prices that are not set by them
so they're dealing with their own
challenges as well yeah and they were
interested about
what people were saying about the food
what people what Farm Workers were
saying about
um the conditions of their housing
um and they were interested also about
how this related to biodiversity because
they that's how they sell the coffee
right through this idea of conservation
so yeah
yes I guess this is sort of a follow-on
to your first response but can you talk
a little bit because most of us are not
gonna many of us are not going to be
involved necessarily in current policy
now what can we do as far as consumer
action we'll talk a little bit about
that like things things we can look for
as consumers
yeah absolutely so I get this question
every time I give this stock so thank
you for asking that
um what you can do the best you can do
is that coffee consumer is buy from your
local roaster because your local roaster
is going to have the most direct
relationship with a farmer somewhere
else and if you can start asking
questions about who those farmers are
and how do they practice their
agriculture how do they produce coffee
where is it located
um then you'll start opening that sort
of line of conversation with roasters
that is
perhaps from a from a consumer and
Market standpoint that's probably the
best rather than thinking about buying
just organic or just you know shade
grown or bird friendly
or even fair trade this is the other
thing with fair trade is that it only
certifies less than five hectares
they do not go in and certified this
massive 360 600 plantations right so
these are really outside of the radar of
certifiers
the the amount of stuff that's going on
there socially it's just a lot of the
times mind-blowing child labor all of
that stuff it's not overseen by those
labels
so while you might be thinking you know
you're you're certainly buying from this
really unique specific sector when
you're buying their trade
um you're overlooking 30 40 of what's
going on in the coffee industry so
buying more
in a personal level with the coffee
roaster gives you a more localized
version of
purchase
thank you
thank you so much
okay
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu